[Music]
we now have some new details in the
crash that killed five cyclists on us-95
prosecutors say
the driver of that box truck had meth in
his system
that crash happened last thursday as you
remember right near searchlight about
60 miles south of las vegas it has
really shaken the cycling community in
and around the valley the i-team's david
charns is live outside las vegas cyclery
right near town center and twain and
that's where there is a memorial for the
victims now stands there david
yeah brian the i-team learning that
45-year-old
jordan barson fell asleep and had
meth in his system when the truck he was
driving
veered off into the bike lane killing
those five cyclists and injuring
several more and take a look here these
are the go spikes
that are outside of las vegas cyclery
tonight
set up as a memorial to the five who
lost their lives now let's tell you what
you know what we know right now
prosecutors
telling us barson fell asleep as he was
driving south from las vegas toward
arizona
on u.s 95 the speed limit there by the
way 75
we've learned barson is 45 years old he
lives in arizona
and works as a truck driver shuttling
items from the valley down to arizona
now investigators telling us today
barson's truck hit those cyclists
in the car escorting them on a 130 mile
ride
prosecutors telling the ice team
troopers obtained a blood sample from
barson right after the crash it took a
couple days now to get those results
back
and they found a quote significant
amount of meth in his system
you put two and two together that you
have methamphetamine
in his system and that he fell asleep at
the wheel
those two factors are extremely
dangerous
barson facing six charges of felony dui
five resulting in death one in bodily
harm and six charges for reckless
driving
the i-team did find a person with the
same name and same age in
arizona who was charged in 1995
on a theft related incident now it's
important to tell you that when speaking
to reporters right after the crash
troopers from nhp said that they did not
think that there was anything reckless
here
that they didn't think the driver was
impaired in any way
right now barson is in an arizona jail
awaiting to be extradited and face
charges here in nevada of course we'll
keep
posted in orco mana we'll have much more
on this tonight at 11.
we're live near town center in twain
tonight i'm david charns 8 news now